[Musique]
nous sommes venus à Rome pour tourner une poursuite
avec beaucoup plus d'ambition et
d'imprévisibilité que nous n'avons pas eu dans les
poursuites précédentes,
nous crierons dans les rues
de Rome Motos
Voitures tout ce que nous avons filmé est
complètement pratique,
nous'  Si nous faisons les choses correctement,
tout se résume à une chose : comment
impliquer le public ? Je veux juste
leur donner ce frisson
[Applaudissements]
Nous laissons la ville nous dire quel genre de
poursuite cela allait être. La circulation dans la
ville est notoire et  les
rues pavées peuvent tomber à la conduite
imprévisible, la
meilleure partie est que Tom et Haley
sont menottés ensemble,
les gens nous poursuivent oui, c'est
vous qui conduisez
[Applaudissements]
Tom qui est tombé menotté d'une main pour de
vrai, ne trichez pas, la clé est de ne pas le faire.  Je ne
m'écraserai pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je n'ai aucune idée
de conduire et de dériver d'une seule main dans
les rues de Rome, c'était le jour où je
n'oublierai jamais d'essayer de faire des dérives
à chaque fois que tu penses que tu vas dans les One
Direction, ce sont les pavés  dans la
rue en disant non, tu ne l'es pas, tu vas par
ici, tu dois te débarrasser de cette voiture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Tom et Haley ont abandonné la voiture pour l'un de
leurs IMF là-bas parce que tout
d'un coup, cette toute petite Fiat 500
sort de  nulle part nous n'avons construit cette Fiat 500
pour qu'elle soit plus rapide, nous
pouvions à peine contrôler la voiture, c'était
traître, la Fiat était sauvage, certains
diraient même que la voiture est possédée,
je ne pense pas que nous aurions pu faire une
séquence plus difficile à
filmer.  si j'avais fait tout mon possible pour
le faire, j'aurais des résultats vraiment étonnants, ce
serait impossible sans cela grâce à
un acteur comme Tom,
nous les avons perdus à
l'étranger